-Our first guest tonight is an
Emmy and Golden Globe-winnin
actress you know from the hi
comedy "Parks and Recreation,"
films like "Mean Girls"
and "Sisters,"
and of course her work on
"Saturday Night Live."
She co-hosts
the show "Making It."
The third season premieres
later this year on NBC.
please welcome back to the show,
our very good friend,
Amy Poehler.
Hello, Amy.
-Hi, Seth.
-It's so wonderful to see you.
You were one of our first
guests when this first hit
back in March.
Do you think you would hav
predicted we would be in thi
situation now, 10 months later
-I did not picture it.
That was 10 months ago,
we had no idea what was ahead.
We probably thought this would
be a fun experiment
for a couple of months,
then we were going to be
having dinner together
in the summer.
Little did we know.
-Little did we know.
Do you -- are you someone wh
would like to know the future,
if that was available to you
-No, no.
Maybe when I was younger,
I thought I would want to know
what was going to happen.
Now I would rather someone jus
put me to sleep,
and wake me up
when everything is better.
My kids were just watching
"The Matrix" the other day
and I was like, is there a
waiting list for The Matrix?
-So "The Matrix" appeals
to you, the longer you go?
-Yeah, yeah.
There are times when
something takes a long time,
and it's really fun.
You know...
and there are times
when something won't end
and it's really stressful.
This is a time when it not
ending is very stressful.
But I do like
those times in life
where things are going on
too long, and you're excited
because it's so stressful,
does that make any sense?
If you go to a wedding and the
dad gets up and starts to give
a speech that is really bad.
And you're not very good friends
with the person getting married.
-Well, I've talked about thi
before, how you were such
good laugher at read-through
And a lot of times at read
through,
I think a bad read-through
sketch is a little bit lik
a wedding toast that goes
off the rails.
Everybody knows right away
and then you have people
that have to sort of very
passionately perform something
knowing that it's tanking.
And you were a great laugher
in those moments.
Do you think that was,
in part --
because I thought you
were doing it
because you were to trying t
make people feel better.
But maybe you were taking
deep, gleeful joy
in knowing that something ba
was going on too long?
-I'm proud of the fact that as
I've gotten a little older
I'm a little bit more
comfortable
with being uncomfortable.
The uncomfortable isn't always
as horrible as it used to be
When I was younger, I was
little bit more co-dependent
and wanted everybody to feel
okay, and I wanted things to
you know, I wanted to smooth
everything out.
Now, the new me, Seth, the new
me just really leans into
that kind of stuff now.
-Well, that's good.
it's a very good time to b
comfortable
with the uncomfortable.
And obviously,
you've always been a forerunner,
in my life,
being a little bit ahead of th
curve as far as
what is the best way.
[ Laughs ]
I have to say, I'm very --
my kids are younger than yours
but that's very exciting tha
one of your kids
was watching "The Matrix."
That seems to me like a jackpo
movie that holds up,
and it must be so fun
to see through their eyes.
-Yeah, it's really exciting when
your kids start to watch thing
and report back to you,
as if you don't know.
I think, you know, like,
my kids would be like,
"You know, Led Zeppelin
has a really good song."
Wow, cool. I'll have to preten
I don't know about it.
Or my little one the other day
was like,
"You know what's cool
about 'SNL'?
It's not always funny,
but it's fun to watch."
-[ Laughs ]
-That's a good bumper sticker.
Look, it's not always funny,
but it's fun to watch.
-I wish instead of the
Broadway video logo at the end
of "SNL," it was just Lorn
pouring a glass of wine,
at the end, it would go to
credits, everybody is hugging.
And then it would be Lorne
he's going,
"It's not always funny,
but it's fun to watch."
[ Laughter ]
Talking about different
generations and your kids,
you directed and star
in this film, "Moxie."
-Seth, that's what I'm her
to talk about,
other than seeing
you and saying hi.
-Right. You said you wanted to
promote two things,
"Moxie" and "The Matrix".
-Yes.
-Because they're, I think,
I don't want to do the checkin
but I think
they're anagrams of each other
[ Laughter ]
I think enough people
knew about "The Matrix."
Keanu Reeves is great.
-So good.
-He's not in "Moxie,"
but "Moxie" is a movie
that I directed,
a film that I directed.
Do you remember movies?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Now, everything is TV.
But there used to be this thin
called movies.
And this is going to be on
Netflix in March.
I'm really proud of it.
We shot it last year.
And it's based off of
the YA novel of the same name.
It's about a young girl's
journey figuring out
what she cares about
and all of the different peopl
and voices that help inform her,
educate her,
and get her motivated.
-I want to talk more
about the difference between
this cast and
the "Wine Country" cast,
which was your last
directorial effort,
and we're going to do that
when we come right back
with more from Amy Poehler